let's see what he has done to this point
17 strikeouts nine walks four home runs
and his 19 innings of work
waiting in the pitch swing and a miss
late on that fastball at 94.
top of the zone one out he went
yes so that close they say a game
of inches two down grandall
towards center here's reynolds he's
there
and they will face the right-hander
dylan sees a lot of left-handers frank
for cease to face today
yeah it doesn't matter if he's got a
half-fast ball working with that
dangerous curveball and that devastating
change up
it doesn't matter if the left or right
or this guy has above average
won the best arms in all the baseball
quiet right-hander out of the state of
georgia dillon sees to adam frazier
there's a curveball and he went around
strike three that was nasty
great curveball adam he's not happy with
that call it was borderline
strike three you can throw it to third
now yes
full count with two outs nobody on
reynolds muscles one in the air out into
center it's going to be caught
by brian goodwin and that's a one two
three
first here's a 3-2 from de young
and it's swinging a fly ball out to left
right toward gamble he'll back up a
couple of steps a little light breeze
today it makes a catch one out
then it will bring up laori who's
playing second base
leori garcia gives it a ride to right
field and this
is out of here jump ball
that's what i'm talking about down that
lineup you need someone to provide a
spark
larry garcia has been so positive for
this club the last three years i really
like his game and that was a big time at
bat
and right away he meant business but
that's just going up there look at the
ambush he got the right pitch
and the right swing he's the right guy
for the moment
he is on his way into second base and
this is a one-out double
first career hit for luis gonzalez
nostradamus over here that is
awesome takes care of him
for the second out now the birthday boy
tim anderson who's old for one
middle middle curve ball drilled left
center field
and this will be two nothing gonzalez
scores tim
anderson plugs one into left center
there it is happy birthday there it is
happy birthday t.a
let's hit deep to right field over by
the corner
oh and a nice grab by polanco
two and two oh he mixed in a curve ball
and it's strike three
that's just not fair
and a line drive toward right and a
bullet off the wall
into second base with a double
1-2 from c swing and a miss he got him
on a change up for his fourth strikeout
slider wrapped to short hopscotch tim to
first
if young can move him over
hard back to the bag a bobble he will
not get either
and a throw into right field
i mean who knows if he gets the throw
off quickly does he get
two he certainly gets one and now he
gets none again it works out to the
pirates he got
one of the hottest hitters in the
national league coming to the plate and
adam frazier
swinging a ground ball to the right side
that will bring the runner home and then
de young
on the hesitation by garcia is able to
get to third on a great base running
play
and so at rbi for frasier the pirates
are on the board it's two to one
two to one white sox now here in the
third here's the pitch by cease
swinging a chop to third over moncada
and trickling into left
it's an rbi single for key brian hayes
just like that again we have a tie ball
game
just one miscue can turn into an
opportunity
so now you need a two-out hit and
polanco doubled off the wall his first
time up
excited for sore eyes great point side
and player that's what
you want to entertain dylan season
feels like here's the pitch strike three
call
well he made up for it looking to get
out of it here and maybe end his day
chase de young and he strikes out abreu
grand all bats with runners at the
corners and
two down and a 2-2 tie three and two
yasmani smokes this ball up the alleyway
into left center
and all the way down the gap to 4-10
lamb will score
easily and it's a two-run double for
grandau
and the sox are up four to two two on
no one out now reynolds and the one-two
there's the ground ball it's anderson at
short he steps on the bag throw to first
it's a double play
right on cue
to second base and garcia throws him out
the more looks i can get a picture the
better my eyes and my chances of doing
some damage
fair ball abreu handles an easy two
pitch out number one
[Applause]
there's a change up you're talking about
from season
perez in the air right center field
goodwin at the track
that's a close one one pitch away from
having a tie ball game
here's hayes swinging a ground ball up
the middle that's going to get through
base hit redwell by fraser he touches
third and he's going to score
rbi single for key brian hayes 4-3 now
here in the seventh
ground ball base hit the left there was
nobody over there on the left side
goodwin on his way to second the throws
gonna be laid he's got a sliding double
now gonzalez making his first big league
start today
three and two and he got him
so liam hendricks out of the bullpen to
try and convert his 19th
save and he'll face nine one and two in
this pirates order
two strikes to evans and down he goes
high fastball one gone
man he's blowing good old countrified
gas
99 99 99 and 99.
there was no surprises there
3-2 pitch ripped to right field on a
line but
it's caught for out number two i mean
this kid is barreling up
everything two pirates retired key brian
hayes
has had a good day he's been on three
times
three and two on the ground to short
tim is there and the sox have won
leaving pittsburgh with a split and a
much needed win
frank thomas coming home with positive
vibe the team needs this
just to w